i've got a heart that needs to mend and
i don't know how this story ends
oh can we make can we make it
work again i know
it won't be easy
wonder if this time it could be real
that was a moving scene from the netflix
holiday film jingle jangle featuring
actress
anika noni rose whose powerful voice you
just heard there
jingle jangle is the first film of its
kind a major motion
christmas musical with all black leading
roles including forest whitaker and
felicia richard
besides offering a much needed ray of
hope in a bleary year the film comes at
an especially critical moment
in america's political consciousness
this year's racial reckoning may have
started with an incident of police
brutality
but its ripples were felt all across the
country in every industry including
hollywood anika is no stranger to making
black history on the big screen
she played the voice of the first
african-american disney princess tiana
in the studio's hit film the princess
and the frog speaking on the 10th
anniversary of that film she said
tiana's impact
transcended racist she was an
inspiration to all girls of color
she told variety babies aren't looking
at her for her skin color they just know
that they feel
something good they are babies and they
recognize her spirit and their heart and
their gumption
and i think that is a great thing in a
world and media landscape where little
boys and girls of color rarely see
people like themselves on screen
films like the princess and the frog and
jingle jangle and actors like anika
open a new generation to a world of
possibilities
and she uses her voice not just on the
big screen but is vocal
on a whole array of social and political
issues in real life
so it gives me great pleasure to say
that anika noni rose joins me on the
show now
thank you so much for coming on the show
tonight this movie
bridges this fantastic world of a
magical
toy shop with everyday issues like
family drama or a greedy rival at work
what does it mean to you to be part of
such a universal message
with such a historic and different cast
well it you know it's it's fantastic and
the glorious thing about it is that the
themes are so universal um
but you get to see this black family
living
a normal flawed and yet magical life
which is not something that we often
get to see um usually there's some sort
of strife that's like
huge and unsurmountable and specific to
their blackness and that's not what this
story is talking about
this story is talking about the magic
not only of love but of belief
um and that's i think that's a beautiful
gift at the time of christmas because we
all need some magic
right now specifically in 2020
oh 100 and it is a beautiful gift and a
lot of people are enjoying the movie
um this film's race conscious casting
comes
a kind of a pivotal moment in modern
american history especially the history
of racism
where do you see this moment meeting the
current
uh the protests the reckoning the black
lives matter movement
uh so much energy that we saw this year
where do you see it fitting into all of
that
well i think that for people who are
consistently used to not seeing
themselves
um in on-screen in general
in a landscape of magic of wonder
um in a holiday situation that
is not talking about lack but is talking
about
um the fullness of love and family
i think that in itself speaks to and the
numbers that it has done the fact that
so many people
are involved with it and excited by it
speak to the fact that these people with
these faces
with this skin are relevant people
in society but also in imagination also
in the hearts and imagination of
children
everywhere and that's what people that's
what we in the industry have been saying
for years while we were being told that
our skin doesn't sell overseas
which we all know is not true um
and we are proving it again and again
and i think that
that's very important to
the momentum and the next step that we
take as
entertainers as people who scope
somebody's mindset of how they feel
about a certain people
when all they've seen of those people is
through their screen
indeed and you've personally proved that
prove them wrong
as i mentioned a moment ago this isn't
your first time making movie history
you gave voice to the first black disney
princess first african-american disney
princess
uh that was a watershed moment 10 years
ago and you held disney to task recently
for an animation you felt
watered down tiana's features you posted
about how you asked disney to explain
new images where she looked very
different with
lighter skin and different features than
the original animation
tell us about disney's response and what
media companies can do
to preserve a more accurate
representation
of actors and bodies in their animated
work
well disney's response was exactly what
i hoped it would be
you know they they heard me they brought
me in we had a meeting
and they they adjusted what needed to be
adjusted
um i don't you know i don't think that
it was a malicious it was with malicious
intent that she was changed
but she was and so they didn't say that
it hadn't happened
they fixed it and i think that it's
really
important to pay attention to people
i i just feel that part of the problem
when we
see ourselves on screen use a
brown-skinned man i'm sure have seen
yourself on screen
in a way that you don't look at all
because they haven't paid attention they
not disney they whomever everyone
hasn't paid attention to anything
outside of the box that
they live in so the things that we may
see are things that are
stereotypical because that's easy to
grab to
and what i'm saying as we move forward
because now we know it's 20 20 we know a
lot of things
some things that maybe we wish we hadn't
had to learn the way that we have
but we know now so it's on us
the creator to pay attention to the
things that matter
and to staff their higher echelons
with people who are also of a different
space in life so that they can have
a space that is representative of the
world not just one piece of the world
yes and as you say the media companies
corporations increasingly getting on
board
with the right message with the message
of inclusivity uh so
in politics uh are our elected
representatives the incoming biden
administration
let me ask questions about what's going
on in politics how much do you think a
new administration can do
and maybe a new senate depending on what
happened in georgia can actually do
bring about change on issues like
criminal justice reform the things we
talk about in abstract but actually
require legislation to change
well i think that what happens in
georgia is
very very imp important um
and people particularly democratic
people or republicans who recognize that
their um party has not done well or
right
need to go out and vote for
warnock and vote for uh oh i'm gonna
mess up his name
i know i messed that up um but it's
important
thank you i thought it was asnef and i
always ruin it but osnov and warnock
are the people that we need to have in
the senate so that change can be made
so that we aren't bulldozed by the
lindsey grahams
and the mitch mcconnells who have their
agenda which is not the agenda of
humanity
which is not the agenda of the humane it
is an agenda that is
old and tired and rank and we must
have some sort of balance to the senate
because i do think change can be made
because when i see what biden has done
with the epa appointments
a native american woman a black man from
south carolina
um a woman from boston who's a self
self-proclaimed hippie who swam in
boston harbor in the 60s when it was
basically trash
these are people who want to and plan to
make a difference and it looks to me
that through the appointments he is
making he also wants to implants to make
a difference that's what we thought was
going to happen
it is really wonderful to see that that
is the path that he is taking but we
have to be vigilant
we can't only vote for the presidential
elections
we must vote in those midterm elections
we must pay attention when sheriffs
are on the docket when judges are on the
docket we must make that part of our
lives and
there is no longer space to say i'm not
i'm not a political person
because you must be um
coronavirus is not a political thing it
is science
and the fact that people are still
running around screaming in folks faces
without masks and running through stores
and having tantrums
like five-year-olds at the risk of their
health and everyone else's
because it has been allowed to be called
political
is unbelievable and insane
so we must bring ourselves back so that
we and we know what actually is
political and we know what actually is
important and we stop playing little kid
games because
the toddler will still be gone soon be
gone and we can act like
adults and burgeoning adults who are
really going to make a difference in the
voting booth
and we can change our country for the
better
well said i think we'll have to leave it
there on that very inspiring note uh
actor anike noni rose
thank you so much for your time
hi i'm mehdi hasan thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date
on the day's biggest stories thank you
for watching